ce qu'elle voit ses gains
déjà tu as mis des gens mais beige metal
mais casting mais dans ma vie ma gauche
qui s'agace un plateau caillou passé mon
enfance plateau jeune apprenti e vieux
brésil mme hasse 14 ans là bas et il
fait 4 ans dans les niches réunion fait
mon sens on my my et m'avait peut-être
un morceau de mon amoureuse il fallait
vite se trouve à lille va et que là où
un moyen vraiment le la connexion entre
la musique et encore plus avec la
réunion puisque quand on voulait loin ou
encore plus connectés et coûtera signer
une théorie coûte encore plus maloya
être cela mais m'a toujours voulu
mélanger vraiment les influences se
cumuler avec le maloya là
[Musique]
un jour ma connu un guitariste a connu
au brésil
les gars qu'on devra et j'ai dit ouais
j'ai fait un hommage
à gainsbourg est ce que tu veux chanter
tu vas être le chanteur bah ouais c'est
sûr l'on est en fait le gars mettent à
moi sur une scène devant 400 500
personnes à san paolo et ça a été le
déclic jim d'y résister
comme on a pu parce que en étant jeune a
fait d'autres un petit singe la réunion
des adolescents mais comme on a pu
glisser après ça on gagne musique et son
maloya aussi au programme musique parce
que d'un influent se tenir maloya avec
eux jazz rock funk lille après son bal
au diable ce que me fait des essais avec
la samba et le maloya compassion la loi
fillon c'est pas ben maloya des
poubelles
c'est sûr avec le surtout bastia où ça
va parler message et après le reggae la
force des messages du rythme apprennent
à tout un dièse grande influence à
moynat les indices comme hendrix aussi
tout fait les bons choix scènes
franchement me regarde toujours bien
inspiré en main
c'est le premier morceau m'a écrit en
route dans la réunion comme un voyage un
petit peu dans le monde brésil cela mais
avec tout le monde les différents
ménages à faire et il fait la richesse
la réunion c'est que nos recettes encore
c'est différent cela donc ma d'imiter
veut faire un hommage à nous te à nos
pays nation où les annexant pour
l'humanité de cathy chanson c'est un
hommage à nous à nous mêmes réunionnais
[Musique]